hello there today we'll look at train
short test long attention with linear
biases enables input length
extrapolation also called alibi by ophir
press noah a smith and mike lewis
so on a high level this paper
replaces the position encodings or
position embeddings of transformers by a
new
very simple system that enables these
transformers to extrapolate to much
longer sequences at infants time than
they have been trained on so you can
train on quite short sequences and then
inference will not suffer will not
degrade even if the inference sequence
length is much longer than the training
sequence length this goes from two times
longer to ten times longer to more
so
this builds on what people have learned
on of position encodings in the last few
years what works and what doesn't and it
sort of advances this one more step
there's still room for improvement after
this but it's quite a simple thing to do
the code is available i'll of course a
link to it in the description and it
seems like
this might might be worth a try if you
implement uh transformer based language
models and you want to infer on longer
sequences than you've trained on give
this a try
as always if you enjoy paper reviews
don't hesitate to subscribe and
tell me in the comments what you think
all right let's get into it so what's
the problem the problem is position
encodings as we've said transformers
were released in 2017 by the original
attention is all you need paper and they
already dealt with the question of
position encodings now why is that
that's because a transformer
fundamentally isn't a sequence model per
se it's actually a set model right so
let's say you have a sequence of tokens
and in this paper we exclusively deal
with sort of autoregressive text
generation but there's no
actual reason why this is the only case
where this should be useful
but
that's what we're dealing with so you
want to predict the next token from a
series of tokens so here you have five
tokens and you want to predict the next
one that comes after that and then the
one after that and then the one after
that and so on
so since a transformer essentially
transforms a sequence of inputs into an
equally sized sequence of outputs in
every layer
the
transformer other than a fully connected
network the transformer itself doesn't
really
know per se where a particular
item is so for example for this node
right here the transformer would
generate the query
and then match that up to keys that are
that are emitted here and then it would
route information via the inner product
however
it it doesn't matter if this node here
for example is here or over here if it
has the same key the information routing
happens the same way
ergo to the transformer doesn't matter
where the inputs are so essentially it's
dealing with the input sequence as a set
and not a sequence now recognizing that
the original transformer already had to
deal with position embeddings meaning
you know if
let's say every sequence element comes
in and initially like the initial
sequence you give every token an
embedding so these are your standard
token embeddings that you know from word
to vec or glove or something like this
so initially you give every token a
similar embedding now let's say these
two tokens here are actually the same
token
so
the
cat and the end okay maybe not but
um
so two words can be the same right in
the in the same sentence
even though they might mean a bit
different things because they're at
different places
so what you want to do is you want to
augment these embeddings right here by
position embeddings and the position
embeddings can be as simple as uh simply
appending
let's say okay to any of these vectors i
append one dimension i simply write the
position in it so this is value zero
this is value one this is value two i
simply append the dimension and i put
the number there
this won't work too well because we're
sort of in
linear space and numbers between zero
and one and so on so there are various
schemes how to do this the first scheme
that the original paper came up with is
this scheme of these sinusoidal
uh encodings which means that
if we let's
let's go down here
this is our sequence how do we make the
position encodings and they said why
don't we or let's make six why don't we
have multiple dimensions of position
encoding so our position encoding is a
vector
now
let's say
that
the
one dimension we simply index
a really long sine wave so the sine wave
would continue back here a really long
sine wave by the position so the this
token would get so here is the
here's the zero
right this is a sine wave so the first
one would be assigned a 0 then this one
would be assigned like a 0.5 this one
like a 0.7
0.5
and so on right you see like
so but then
these aren't unique right for example
this and this they have the same one on
the first
dimension let's say well in the second
dimension we'll do a sine wave but we'll
make it double
double as fast
like this okay and now again we index
all the tokens by where they are so this
again would be 0 this may be 0.7 here
now this would be
also 0.7 maybe and now this would be
this is almost this is like
0.1
so now you can see this vector here is
already different from this vector here
so as you build up your sine waves you
can make them even faster
right and even faster as you build that
up you eventually get unique
representations for each position but
also the advantages and and that's what
the original paper hypothesized is that
now the transformer can reason sort of
about distances between tokens so it can
say well if two things are
relatively close
you know in this top most dimension
right here i can be reasonably sure
they're kind of close together right but
how close together well if they're also
pretty close in the lower dimensions
then they're probably right next to each
other right or you can say well i want
something that's like
you know medium size apart from from
this word that i'm on not right next to
it but you know kind of a way so it
would look for something that's kind of
different in one of these dimensions so
the hypothesis was that you know with
these things it could reason about
absolute and relative positions uh from
the tokens to each other
right it it doesn't have to learn that
where relationship between word one and
word three
and word two and word four separately
you could actually just learn at one
point the relationship between any two
words that are a bump apart in this
dimension and then that would replicate
across
and it could potentially also
extrapolate however this didn't turn out
to work
really well
and that is for
two reasons
at least this paper makes it seem like
that's for two reasons the first reason
is that
it it doesn't like the embeddings
themselves don't really seem to
extrapolate that well so the functions
that are learned from these embeddings
it's not like they transfer to longer
sequences
as as much that's the first point the
second point is these vectors that we
build up here
the position encodings what
what they were doing is they were simply
adding them
to the vectors that are the word
embeddings and you know that works fine
i guess especially if you also train the
word embeddings at the same time the
model can sort of circumvent that but as
you go up the layers
as you go up the layers
you have to carry through this
information so now all your computations
within a layer have to first of all deal
with what are the meaning of the tokens
and how they relate to each other but
second it would also have to carry
through this positional information to
the upper layers
and that's where more follow-up
positional encodings made at sort of a a
difference
in that for example they said something
like well
we don't want to just add them to the
bottom we also we kind of want to inject
them into every layer separately right
we inject them here we inject them up
here and so on so the model always has
access to the position encodings first
hand and doesn't need to carry through
this information so this is one of the
improvements that has happened
the second improvement is to simply
switch up the the sinusoidal encodings
uh by themselves and that's a thing that
we're going to see today
and the third is actually related to the
first one a little bit is that um
if
you know if you say i'm gonna inject the
position information everywhere it also
matters where and how you eject the
position information so as you might
know if there is an incoming
incoming embedding here
um for every token we're actually going
to create a query a key and a value
and
the trick seems to be that if i only
inject the position information into the
query and the key
and not the value right
if i inject it into the query and the
key i influence how information is
routed here that influences that but
then the actual information that's
transmitted to the next layer those are
the values and
i do not inject the position information
into the values at all therefore the
information that flows from layer to
layer to layer
has no positional information in it
at all at least not directly because the
value
the values remain
information of
position information free
we inject the position information at
every layer into the queries and the
keys or the computation that we do with
them
right so these are the sort of
improvements that came together in the
last few papers
uh
they compare different embeddings right
here so
this sinusoidal is the original one
rotary embeddings as they're used in
gptj
t5 bias as it's used in t5 and then
their new one alibi and here you can see
this model for example is trained on
tokens in its training distribution
however when they
inference when they make do inference on
longer tokens you can see right here
everything performs you know quite well
this is perplexity lower is better
if you go longer the sinusoidal
embeddings shoot up immediately so they
fail immediately also the the rotary
embeddings they don't seem to cope super
well a bit more but not super well so
even if you go double the sequence
length they sort of fail the t5 bias is
better
but the t5 bias is a learned embedding
takes more memory and needs longer to
compute and to train
which is a disadvantage there also it
degrades relatively quickly and then the
alibi embeddings that they suggest they
are not learned they are fixed
embeddings like the sinusoidal and the
rotary embeddings but they can deal with
way longer sequences right here so they
keep up the speed of
not having to learn embeddings they keep
up the not wasting memory on things
because they're not learned
they they don't increase the computation
time and they manage still to bias the
model in a way that it can extrapolate
too much longer sequences so how how
does it do this
um yeah so here you can see memory stays
relatively low doesn't increase
inference speed stays relatively high
training speed stays relatively high
how does it do this here is the main
model the main way that we do this
so
if
as i said we're dealing with
autoregressive language modeling which
means that we're dealing with causal
attention that's why only a triangular
matrix appears right here there is in my
mind not really a reason why this can't
be extended to full self attention um in
this case you just fill in sort of the
rest of the triangular matrix right here
um
but consider again our model of
transforming a sequence to another
sequence and just view one single token
like this token right here
this token produces q2 query two
and it pays attention to all of the keys
in the input sequence right this is the
attention mechanism
the query is multiplied with all of the
keys to decide where it should get its
information from okay now if we simply
do it like like this and this is with
the with the causal attention it can
only actually pay attention to all the
keys that come before it so query 2
would be multiplied only by key 1 and
key 2 and not key 3 because it can't
look into the future
so if it were just that then as you can
see from this calculation there is no
notable difference between these and
these right it depends only on what the
key is
to decide on the information not the
position at all
now what we do is pretty pretty simple
we simply add
um
the distance between the two positions
so for query 2 and key 2 this here the
distance is zero because they are the
same position in the sequence so the uh
this is not token number two in layer
l
and this up here is token also number
two in layer
i'm terrible at doing else l plus one
okay that's
that's there is no if there is no if
it's the same token we don't do anything
other than that we add the distance or
we subtract the distance right here
multiplied by a number m
this is really a number so i was also
surprised m is a number just a number
like
0.7 or something like this so
you can see
the further into the past
a given key is so
the further into the past the more is
subtracted from the attention value
remember these things here are attention
values these things decide if if this is
high that means that oh
key three is really relevant for query
three right if this is high it means key
two is really relevant for query number
five okay
and this what this here does is it
simply says
well however
the further in the past it is the more
we are simply going to subtract from
that value so whatever value you compute
however important it is
the further in the past the more we're
simply going to subtract from it and
we'll do that in a linear fashion right
so
if your token is here and you look back
then it's sort of
degrades linearly
you know you just subtract more and more
and more and more from that value you
can go you can go negative as much as
you want
why uh why does why does this make sense
i was first a bit confused and like wait
you just subtract like it seems like you
might want to multiply or something like
this but remember
once for example for query 2 here we
built the multiplication
sorry this is a bit heavy
we built the multiplication of
query2 and key2 right this is an inner
product
and we also built the multiplication of
query 2 and key 1. now what do we do
with the two things we do a max which
means that
um
these are numbers and they go into a
soft max which is going to give us a
distribution the softmax is something
like e to the
query to key i
divided by sum over
uh j e query two key j
so they go into
an exponential function and now you can
see why uh subtracting something makes
sense because essentially here we're
working this is log space
and therefore subtracting something in
log space essentially means that you
multiply it or you you divide it
by a constant and you divide it
multiple times or by a higher constant
the more in the past it is
there we go
if this would be the histogram without
the biases you know with the biases you
simply say well whatever is more recent
so the more of the right ones is going
to be even more important after the soft
max of course it's normalized so this
gains in importance and this would drop
in importance whatever it is right even
if it were even if it were
this is higher initially than this um
it would just decrease whatever is in
the past
and sort of remain whatever is close by
actually it decreases everything
but it decreases whatever is in the past
more
so it's just a bias that says whatever's
in the past is less important
now i told you this m is a number so how
do they pick the number and they simply
come up with a scheme they just they
were just like okay so
first of all here's the formula
so
for
routing
to to token i
you take the query multiplied by all the
keys and simply uh add
m times this vector right here
now i'm not sure if
you know that the order needs to be the
order needs to be correct so i guess if
this is the vector right here uh the the
keys have to be sort of reverse order or
something like this because this is the
most this adds to the most recent
token this to the second most recent
token and so on
so here is how they
choose m
m is different for each layer
right
no m is different for each head sorry
m is different for each head
so
they say okay if we have eight heads
the slopes that we use are the geometric
sequence
the geometric sequence that starts at a
half and multiplies each element by a
half to compute the next element
for models that require 16 slope heads
it's it's a bit different
so as you know transformers they have
multiple heads so if the if the this
attention computation is essentially
split
um so you have incoming signal and the
attention computation is essentially
split over multiple heads the attention
computation is done somehow here
and then it's averaged or added together
at the end
and they're simply saying well this m
number in these different heads
should be different
because it might be more useful to have
a harder slope it might be more useful
to have a flatter slope
so
they come up with this scheme where they
say the slope is one half and the slope
here is one
this is a quarter
the slope here like it's so it's
slightly less slopey here it's slightly
less slopey and so on so they have these
almost like different options
uh and i quite
like
i quite like that um because i think
whenever you have sort of parallel
things in your architecture like
multiple heads for attention and
i it's my personal opinion that you
should do something to make them
different from each other otherwise you
just sort of rely on noise and you build
an ensemble which is cool right
ensembles are cool i think you can make
them more effective if you say
all of these different options they're
slightly different in how they work and
the model can therefore choose a bit
which one to utilize uh most now you can
you could still replicate those if you
want more capacity or or anything like
this but i'm i'm generally a fan of
doing something like like that so all
the heads have slightly different scopes
slopes as you can see
in how important or how unimportant they
make the past
and these slopes are predefined by them
and that's it so
yeah that's that the m is one number per
head um in the fashion that we've shown
the
and it's really simple the drop-off is
completely linear right
and the simplicity might be the key
right here because
now we test whether this extrapolates in
the experimental results and you can see
that this extrapolates quite well
so i already shown you before of course
the the perplexity um
it what in what they what they've shown
but here is another
another test on the wiki text data set
so again we have perplexity on the
y-axis
and the
square dots you see they are always the
classic sinusoidal embeddings and they
are always trained on
as long sequence as you test because
we've already seen if you make the
sequence longer they just fail uh so
here the comparison is really you train
on a sequence and
and that is exactly the length of the
testing sequence so they should be
perfectly adapted to that length now the
top line
is the new embeddings
trained on
512 so the top line is trained
on this size yet if you test it
it already performs better now
what do you what do you make of what do
you
i don't know what you make of this like
the claim is somehow
well
it's just a better position embedding by
itself because you can see here it's
already better i don't know maybe this
is also just experimental
like machine learning experiments in
papers always making the baseline worse
than themselves but what we can say is
that
you can see
it
generally the perplexity decreases
or remains constant as you up the scale
even if you've trained it on small
on a small length
and
when you actually train it on larger
lengths so this line starts here the one
they trained here obviously i guess they
could test it on shorter sequences but
what's the point
you
become even better because you've
trained on longer sequences right and
again you see the same pattern also with
the one that you trained on
very long input so
in general you see
on long texts the perplexity
decreases
as you train for longer obviously right
so it still has an effect you still want
to train on as long sequences as you can
because that will gain you in
performance
however
it's not
it's not too bad if you train on short
sequences and then extrapolate to longer
ones with this embedding in contrast to
the sinusoidal embeddings that just
completely fail when you give them
anything longer than like 1.1 times the
training length
and they have various uh comparisons
about
um
perplexity and how many words per second
here is a cool plot that shows you know
if you
train on the same length as the
sinusoidal embeddings
you get much lower perplexity and only a
tiny bit of a slowdown it seems because
probably because you inject the
position encodings into
every layer by the way have you seen
here the position encodings they only go
to the query and key computation they
don't go into the values at all we don't
add them to the embeddings at the
beginning so this is exactly one of the
things we talked about at the beginning
so this is how they sort of incorporate
one of the learnings of the last years
so because you have to do this every
layer it's a tiny bit slower but you
gain a lot in perplexity and if you go
if you go to train with smaller
sequences obviously you're going to be
faster and as you can see your
perplexity it doesn't suffer too much
in fact in their experiments again
take it with a grain of salt but in
their experiments it is even lower
than the full length training with the
sinusoidal embeddings
so they go into as i said into various
experiments right here in generally
their message is
always the same there is a weird
phenomenon where the perplexity actually
gets better
as you go beyond
your training length and they attribute
this
in part to the so-called early token
curse phenomenon where it depends sort
of on how you split your evaluation data
and if they modify that they see that at
least as i understand it
they can say that okay if for some
evaluation protocols we actually don't
get better so it's probably due to this
early token curse but nevertheless the
perplexity stays flat or you don't
suffer that much if you
uh train on short sequences
hey this is yannick from the future just
a short addendum here to make it clear
and they also describe this in the paper
what is probably happening isn't that
the transformer is all of a sudden able
to reason about much longer contexts but
what is probably happening is that it
still only looks at the most recent
context because the more distant past
has been down weighted so much by these
biases that it becomes irrelevant but
nevertheless uh it still enables the
transformer to handle these long
sequences and potentially if something's
really important in the past you can
pick up on that all right back to the
video
so
all in all i think this is a very very
simple cool paper i want to see in
practice really if this works out if
this does something again they've only
tested on language modeling auto
regressive language modeling
where
i'm not exactly like i'm not exactly
sure why they haven't tested it on other
things maybe they have and i've just not
noticed it though
it should work in other things but only
time will tell if this is really a if
this is really worth something if this
is really
useful in practice if there are so many
cases where you can only train on
shorter things
yet evaluate on longer things
that's why i would be also interested
in
non-other regressive language modeling
tasks because if you have to say answer
a question about a document right it's
much more about integrating whole
information about the document or
finding relevant things in the document
um and there i'd be interested in the
discrepancy between training and
inference
all right this was it i hope you sort of
understood what it is check out the the
code apparently it's really pretty
simple to include this in any sort of
existing transformer
and
yeah tell me what you think that was it
bye bye